[Music]
spatial Computing is the newest term
that you'll hear be tossed around and
until you actually experience the Apple
Vision Pro in real life it might be hard
to grasp now I know it was for me until
I put this headset on for the first time
and everything just clicked It's ability
to transport you into another world
while staying inside of your comfy cozy
Apple ecosystem is what really sets this
apart from other headsets of course the
price does as well but this really is
unlike anything I've ever experienced
the entire headset is so nice and
everything feels like a high quality
Apple product as you'd expect it's got
this beautiful aluminum frame with the
digital crown and this button right on
top the front is made of a custom curved
glass and under it is actually a display
that will showcase to the outside world
when you're watching content or it'll
display A visual representation of the
user's eyes when you're talking to
someone the inside is an ultra high
resolution display that has 23 million
pixels across the two displays which is
more than a 4K TV for each one of your
eyes